ok müssen alle zuschauer hier auf die
lowcost diese tests geben diese
brutalität tagung live aus dem raum w01
in der prämienstraße 67 aus dem hörsaal
ein spannendes programm und wir schauen
wir auch schon wirklich mit sie alles
herrlich da also wir grüßen alle und wir
hoffen das sind viele
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer hier sind
es kommen noch in diesen raum und diese
vorträge hier diskutieren da und onlive
das wlan gibt alles gibt es alles zu
abwasser es in jeder minute erneut im
lande leute kundenbedürfnisse sind
gedeckt und wir haben die twitter wand
die die frau hauptturm jetzt gleich
vorne installieren bisschen tat
schreiten als test wird aufgezogen
das sagen alle mal hat lohnt also
die ganze aktion zu einem inzwischen
also ich habe hier benutzte kann denn
angeblich beschließen ihr gesagt haben
sagen einfach meinem schuss lassen einer
halben stunde bis zum 13